Donald Trump went golfing this weekend as
Corona virus deaths are going to hit 100000.
Maybe they already have.
By the time you're listening to this, maybe
they are minutes from reaching 100000 American
corona virus deaths.
That's happening just weeks after Donald Trump
said the total, total, total death toll would
be 60000.
And I have to tell you, I understand the outrage.
I don't really care about Trump's golf in
principle.
Once again, you know, this entire Trump golfing
thing has become like so many other things,
a proxy or a signal for a different issue.
The issue with Trump golfing is that he's
failing at almost everything and barely does
any work.
He often watches five hours of cable TV in
the morning, strolls into work around noon
or even later.
If Trump was leading a world class Corona
virus response and he was playing golf, I
wouldn't care who would really care if the
guy was doing a good job and keeping Americans
safe.
But he's not.
And so there's that aspect.
And then there's as all eyes, almost always
with Donald Trump, there's the aspect of incredible
double standards and hypocrisy.
Trump attacked Barack Obama for golfing all
the time.
Obama golfed a fraction of what Trump did
and was never dealing with a global pandemic
with hundred thousand American death toll.
One example, back in 2014, Donald Trump tweeted,
quote, Can you believe that with all of the
problems and difficulties facing the U.S.,
President Obama spent the day playing golf.
And yet, Donald Trump this weekend, as we
approached the horrifying number of one hundred
thousand Americans death dead because of coronavirus.
And in May, not in June or August, as many
models predicted.
Donald Trump is golfing.
Our friend Brian Class, who's been a guest
on the show a couple of times, posted a collage
on Twitter.
Of the many times Trump attacked Obama for
golfing, Obama golfing while the TSA falls
apart.
Obama golfing while a Marine is in Mexico.
Obama golfing during Ebola during which two
people died.
So this is not really about playing golf.
This is about Trump's failures.
This is about Trump's hypocrisy and this is
about Trump's lethal incompetence.
Trump ran on.
I'm gonna be too busy, too rarely, if ever
leave the White House when I'm president of
the United States.
But he's golfed more than anybody.
Trump criticized his predecessor for golfing,
even in the absence of anything even remotely
approximating a global pandemic.
Never mind a global pandemic on which he has
failed.
Trump said Obama shouldn't be golfing when
two people died.
So I don't need the golfing to stop.
I need the dangerous incompetence and hypocrisy
to end acting more quickly would have saved
so many lives.
Getting a working testing and contact tracing
program in place would have saved so many
lives.
There's a new study from Columbia University
which says that just one week earlier for
shutting down restaurants and businesses could
have saved thirty five thousand of the hundred
thousand that have died so far.
Thirty five out of the hundred thousand study
from the University of Southern California
over the last few days found similar numbers,
made similar estimates.
Looking at how South Korea responded, I mean,
I'm like a broken record at this point.
Looking at South Korea is very, very relevant.
So, yeah, I mean, the golf club trips to his
own clubs funnel money into his family's pockets.
He's violating the emoluments clause Secret
Service by renting all of those golf carts
and then paying Trump's own business for those
golf carts is just a way for Trump to profit
from his presidency.
It's not just this way that he's violating
the emoluments clause.
That doesn't change.
The taxpayers are paying for.
I get all of it.
But the golf in and of itself is not the issue.
It's the hypocrisy and the degree to which
Trump's incompetence and laziness is now leading
to a very real death toll, six figure death
toll in the United States alone.
And he is continuing to golf despite criticizing
his predecessor for doing it and saying he
wouldn't be golfing.
It's the presidency that has to end.
Let him play all the golf he wants.
He can play thirty six seventy two holes a
day if he wants.
Once we've removed him from office.